the demon moons are the strongest demons
after muzon and the strongest of all the
demon moons is upper rank 1 kokushibo
kokushibo's real name is michikatsu
tsugikuni and 500 years ago he was
actually one of the most powerful demon
Slayers and he used the breath of the
Moon breathing style he was also the
twin brother of the strongest Demon
Slayer in history yorichi tsugikuni the
man who invented the original breathing
style breath of the Sun as a human
kokushibu lived in the shadow of his
stronger brother and he dreamed of one
day surpassing him but he eventually
realized that he would die before
becoming strong enough to defeat his
brother yorichi so muzan was able to
convince kokushibo to become a demon
because that would give him more time
and power to get stronger than his
brother subscribe to anime uproar for
more Demon Slayer content right now